une jeune fille présente dans public
était formidable une un sourire
incroyable une gentillesse voilà on l'a
aulas qui fait long feu n'a été tiré au
sort et elle est venue jouer avec nous
et elle portait elle portait un voile
regardez la séquence que vous allez voir
les tweets qui ont suivi après qui nous
ont beaucoup beaucoup choqué on voulait
absolument parler ce soir regarde si un
jour le 13 merci fait la merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes alors je vérifie
vous êtes bien le très chaude c'est
magnifique parce que je vous fais un
bisou
merci donné comment ça va quand vous
appelez d'amiens alors bluff ou pas
bluff damien bluff penser que cette
histoire est fausse
bluff cette histoire est fausse et l'ont
toujours gagné personne est allé vite la
nature sous six mois
la montre connectivité là
on embrasse alliage vous faire car
viendra devoirs et les chéris je vais
pas lire les tweets parce que il ya eu
plein de tweets derrière voilà qui qui
ont dénoncé le fait que tania jouer avec
nous alors ça a été vraiment horrible
voilà moi je pense surtout à tania je
suis allée la bienvenue sur le plateau
quand elle veut voilà toutes les femmes
quelles qu'elles soient sont les
bienvenus sur le plateau le plateau est
ouvert à tout le monde vous le dis on a
vu que j'ai vu en plus cela le lh d'un
ancien ministre aussi de la culture qui
disait qu'on est à 8 go homophobes ici
dans cette émission alors je peux vous
dire ici s'il y avait une émission qui
est homophobe c'est bien là et je peux
vous dire on n'acceptera jamais ça ici
l'émission est ouvert à tout le monde
sauf aux cons voilà je vous dis les cons
vous soyez
boudier les cherrière que vous soyez
jeunes quel que soit votre couleur
quelle que soit voilà votre sexe quel
que soit voilà tout ce qu'ils voient là
nous on s'en fout de tout ça on est
juste on a juste là pour rigoler on est
là pour la tolérance pour partager et je
peux vous dire nous on est là pour le
dialogue avec tout le monde même ceux
qui nous critiquent voilà on est on est
là vraiment pour rigoler je vous le dis
tp c'est une émission de divertissement
et on accepte tout le monde ici au
contraire n'ont fait pas de différence
fait de différence voilà en fait jamais
de différence et c'est peut-être ça
aussi qui fait la force de l'émission et
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui des pmp et le
premier talk show de france et que vous
soyez nombreux à le regarder parce que
j'espère que ça réunit tout le monde et
que vous avez l'impression voilà d'être
en famille ici et de voir voilà en tout
cas un échantillon de la société notre
société d'aujourd'hui et j'ai été
vraiment très très peiné par ses tweets
surtout pour tania voilà et que tania ne
regarde pas ça elle s'en fout totalement
nous on aime on aime fort et j'espère
que vous aussi mes chéris et elle
revient quand elle veut sur le plat
[Applaudissements]